Tom Bergeron reveals his father passed  away I want to take a moment to say that  my dad loved this job never missed an  episode I would like to think that  somewhere the Dancing with the Stars  host was back to work on Monday after  taking time off last week to be by his  father's side tom is seemingly keeping  his spirits up instagramming this photo  of his dressing room saying laughter is  the best medicine  he also posted this smiling photo  reflecting in the caption at my wedding  and in my life the best fan  r.i.p Tom thanked his Twitter followers  for their thoughts and prayers and  shared some sage wisdom from his pops my  dad looking back on his life had one  word for all of his worries  insubstantial nicely said  you